When we were in Afghanistan,
there was a warlord who was 14 years old
and he had just taken over his,
uh,
his villages from his father who had
been killed,
uh,
just a couple of weeks before we met
him.
And he's in a very remote region,
just south of the instrument pass,
whether it was a dividing a range,
um,
between those Taliban held a series of
hills that were Taliban held in a series
of hills that were held by his villages.
And he took us up to the place where his
father had been sniped and well made it
a big point of pride to stand at the top
of the mountain where his father had
been shot a couple of weeks ago and sort
of almost daring the Taliban who were
shooting at us from the,
uh,
from the opposing hillside.
You know,
we were sort of ducking and covering.
But you know,
this young 14 year old wanted to show us
that he wasn't afraid to stand in the
exact spot where his father had been
killed.
And,
uh,
and of course the only way to get up
there,
it was on,
on horseback and I'm new equestrian,
but,
uh,
I was able to sort of hang onto this
horse photographers with is a Irish.
I'm a photographer,
was,
uh,
unable to ride a horse,
so he was on a donkey and,
um,
and it was terrifying.
It was funny because I was watching him
on a document.
It's terrifying because they were
shooting at us and he was a [inaudible]
name is seamus,
and he's a fantastic photographer who
later became a great equestrian because
he learned his lesson and Afghan.